In order to rationalize this denominator, we want our powers of 2, x and y to
be divisible by 3. This means, we'll going to to have 2 cubed, x to the 6th,
and y to the 9th. We need to up these powers, so that way they're divisible by
3. So, to change 2 to the 1 to 2 to the 3, we multiply by a cube root of 2
squared. This means, we have to multiply by the cube root of 2 squared x to the
1 y squared. This is so that way the powers sum to multiples of 3. We'll 2 to
the 1 and 2 squared, which is 2 to the 3rd. x to the 5th and x to the 1, which
is x to the 6th. And y to the 7th times y squared, which y to the 9th. Since we
multiply a denominator by this expression, we multiply our numerator by the
same expression. Now, we want to simplify. Our numerator stays the same, since
we can't pull out any of these factors, since they don't appear three times.
This denominator simplifies to 2 x squared and y to the 3rd. Remember, we're
just applying power divided by root to get each of these powers. And we can
actually simplify further. The 6 and the 2 reduce to 3 divided by 1. And this
power of x reduces with 1 of the powers in the denominator. In other words,
we'll have 1 more power of x in the denominator, than we would in our
numerator. This leaves us with our simplified answer. Now, the hardest part to
this problem is understanding what to multiply by here. I think if you start by
figuring out what your denominator should look like, you'll get there more
quickly.